hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the 2023 national
championships well as promise we do have
a very special guest in studio the
founder of the St Louis chess club Rex
singfield Rex they just allow everybody
in
studio welcome welcome welcome well you
were trying to get a special person you
couldn't find him so you got I know I
know we we we we did our best Rex
seriously uh as we were coming into the
show we started talking what do we want
to discuss about and I said well just
you know the the the the list of things
that you've done from the St Louis chess
club the World Chess Hall of Fame the S
St Louis University your uh trustee
there then it started to become like Rex
what aren't you affiliated with here in
St Louis and you found one thing well I
said Washington you but there are a lot
of them but I'm not affiliated with a
lot of hospitals a lot of colleges yeah
there's a whole bunch of them none of
them want me
so Rex I just got to say the studio that
was built here it's just fantastic I
mean I know this is your first
experience what do you think with the
new cameras the whole thing it's great
what's really special about it those who
got the world's three greatest
commentators I was
fishing for that compliment I saw the
hook I
very very recks another national
championships they're they're brilliant
they just get better every year the
players came out they're fighting so
hard what's your looks like we're going
to have a repeat National Champion right
with possibly in the open section right
yeah the Way's doing a point ahead
exactly and I think he's doing well
today in the game you were saying
exactly against was your pick at the
beginning
Rex am I not supposed to
notice I said we're not piing notice
that I said am I not I didn't say aren't
I people say that to sound intelligent
but it actually makes them sound stupid
okay I vented on
that you've dodged the question am I not
supposed to be officially
neutral I don't know I didn't want to
put you on the spot so let let's CR that
question all right okay one of the
things that you are on is the US chess
trust right one of the things that the
US chess trust does does is administer
the Sanford Fellowship one of the things
about uh the Sanford Fellowship is over
the years you they've given away so many
of the scholarships for the trust then
the trust has supported check this out
wow of all the Women's Champions of the
US Champions these are winners of the
Sanford uh chess trust they get a
special um amount of money a large
amount of money to to do training and
you can see you've just we have all the
Playa Crush Curry s Alice Lee Jennifer
they're currently playing in this
tournament yes exactly Alice Lee and
Mishra 14 years old every one of them
know um I mean it's almost like a a
crystal ball if you want to know who the
future champions of American chess are
just look at who won the Sanford fight
we're like a a training tournament here
you know exactly exactly so
congratulations on that performance now
let's talk about uh the um the St Louis
uh chess club for just a moment I mean
coid ruined everybody ruined everything
we're coming out of that we caught up
last year we had the 14 player Fields
we've got the grand chest Tor finishing
uh the singfield cup I know that's
something that you really enjoy I enjoy
it right and uh tell us about uh what's
coming uh for the club
in the month St Louis rapid and Blitz
coming up exactly and then the sinkfield
cup I think that's the biggie
tournaments for the year then yeah
that's the Finish we get to hear
Christian Chilla one of the world's
greatest commentators
well we already had Wesley So Yesterday
doing him a solid I mean you
know Wesley loves me I mean thank you
Rex for this compliments I really
appreciate that for sure
right okay so you got the grand chest
tour that's completed but that will be
continuing uh next year I know that one
of your great Ambitions is you know a
repeat of 1886 at St Louis hosting a
world championship so that's still on
your uh that's still on my wish list
okay but I think we have to get a St
louison to be in
it okay might be and I think we're we
have a good possibility of that with
exactly two or three so yeah so we have
a candidates coming up we will have
Fabian Karana there who already
qualified we may have hiar Nakamura
there who may qualify by rating I
believe uh how amazing is that for I
mean American chess and the possibility
for having a world champion I think it's
it's just wonderful the only thing would
be more wonderful is I if I
qualify but that we don't have to worry
about that just a second let me call up
Vegas in the betting line yeah no but if
we have two candidates there that's
wonderful and uh be the second time for
Fabby think could be the first for Caro
wouldn't
it his qualified cand before and we're
still not sure whether Hikaru will make
right we got the Isle of Man of man is a
big one that's coming up hikaro and
Fabiano actually are fin for position in
that one as well but yes Fabiano
guaranteed he qualify through all the
memes necessary the World Cup a rating
probably he's going to qualify through
that as well and he's playing the aisle
of man as well so he's trying to qualify
through every single means possible
exactly good for him quick question for
you now now we're GNA get some
controversy we're g to poke you a little
bit um bad boy of Chess Hans nean he's
in the tournament you love it you love
it you think it's great to have him in
the compe I think it's great to have him
he's gotten a lot of bad undeserved
press he's been unfairly criticized uh
from many news vehicles around the world
I think it's just ridiculous right and
uh we have no experience with him
cheating there's no one here that I've
ever heard say he's a problem that way
because he's demonstrably not a problem
that way exactly that is absolutely true
I'm so happy you said that that was just
thank you I was hoping I got
that you he did it really good Kate you
have more questions for our founder yes
uh I mean one thing is really the US
championships for me you you know I
transferred Federation I started to play
for the United States and playing those
championships and growing through the
chess of playing against strong players
I'm just very grateful for everything
you do for us and for women's chess also
because I know you are supporting the
women's Olympic team national team
actually I think the next year we are
planning some camps to have together so
I just want to say that we really
directly benefit and we a lot more
exactly for women they deserve it and
chess needs it well one of the things
that you've done is you've opened up
your own home I mean Faby had a training
camp there and I think the ladies uh
jealously said okay we'll have a
training camp
at you're going to be hosting the US
Women's team before you know it Wesley
was there for a month some years ago my
grandson who's now 10 was five at the
time and Wesley played him of course and
toyed around with him and so I asked him
later I said so what do you think about
Wesley he says oh he's good but I beat
himy and you know the club also
organizes a lot of like summer classics
spring Classics a lot of other
tournaments to grow new talents new
generations of chess player so what do
you say about Alice Lee and abanu Mishra
I mean good such Superstars yeah I mean
you're talking about new Talent we've
got some incredible new Talent right
here and if they keep coming along at
that rate it it's just hard to imagine
you what's going to be there and how
good they're going to be Rex I just just
want to say thank you so much for
everything you do it's absolutely uh
wonderful and uh keep it
up just keep it up you're both very kind
you still don't know what the hell
you're talking we got that uh here are
our current standings as we're in round
10 of these national championships the
ladies have just been incredible Kate
absolutely B here J storming